is absolutely tragic situation i have to
admit and in the five days i had to
listen to so many
absolutely horrible stories from people
who i know and love and just from
strangers who were contacting me on
facebook with the hope of escaping
and i just keep receiving emails and
calls in the middle of the night of
people just crying and asking to help
their elderly parents
those families with disabled children
and they're just really desperate to get
out and they can't stay there because
the humanitarian crisis is
reaching a
tragic level
so yes we've all been working hard but
it's getting so much harder and it's
getting so much more dangerous just to
travel within ukraine
and nobody has given any roots
if if just a week ago you could get some
sort of safe routes out
now it's it's desperate and it's not
doable unfortunately
i was telling about my attempts of uh
getting my niece out of kiev and uh
i was
advocating her taking the train and
there was a worry it felt like a safe
option
but there is no such thing as a safe
option now and my husband was saying
like look with russians i'm a history of
bombing civilians and especially
targeting green courage as we shouldn't
be doing it and there's been a big
family discussion argument we didn't
know how to do it
so yes the worry is always there but
hope is all we have
i mean
if there's no green courages people will
just start starving and dying just even
more needlessly than it already is and
it's such cruelty it's a war crime in
the middle of europe and i still am and
just believe that it's happening i won't
lie to you
my niece managed to escape with her
mother and her sister and they're in
europe waiting for their visas at the
moment so they are relatively safe
but i wish i could say it's a happy
ending like it's not the broken the
distraught my sister is a successful
career woman who managed a chain of
restaurants just two weeks ago you know
people lived their lives planned
holidays
children went to school
and overnight their lives were ruined
she's coming with nothing as she was
saying to me how do you pack a life in
one suitcase
you know
yes it's going to be a very very long
road to recovery
my sister has a great help in the face
of me who's gone through this
immigration route myself so i've gone
through my first visa to citizenship i
know how it's all filled in i'm pretty
much an immigration lawyer
half part time so i've taken care of all
the paperwork for her
using my knowledge and expertise and my
connections even but i'm scared to think
about those people who don't have the
privilege of having somebody
on the ground who could resolve all this
and i'm working with other organizations
just offering help
uh with translation with paperwork
um yeah so i hope it's it's actually
quite smooth i hope it's gonna be just a
matter of days
my mother says how can we leave this is
our land this is our house where we
raised you
where we raised our grandchildren and
she said that she's already planted her
radishes and
flowers for the next season so she can't
leave her garden you know
it's um yeah so they a lot of people
think the same way
they say like this is our home
we're staying